sha award for the year 2013 2014 it is
my pleasure to invite Dr Zakir n on the
stage welcome Dr
Zak the Sha award for the year 2013 that
is 1434
hury it's a great pleasure and honor for
me the Sha award for voluntary work
committee under the patronage of shikh
Dr Sultan bin Muhammad
Alim M of the Council of UAE and ruler
of sha has appreciated Dr Zak nik's
voluntary services to
Islam and will be conferring Dr Zak
Knight with the shaja award for
voluntary work for the year 2013 that is
1434 H at a ceremony at the alrai Hall
University of shja UAE on 15th rabi a
1435 H that is Thursday 16th January
2014 at 9:30 a.m. it's a great pleasure
and honor for me to be awarded the
Islamic personality of the Year 2013 Dr
Z mik was presented the Dubai
International Holy Quran Awards Islamic
personality of the Year 2013 by Sheikh
Muhammad bin Rashid al- mum the vice
president of UAE and ruler of Dubai
on 29 July 2013 in Dubai UAE please join
me in welcoming Dr Zakir n to the stage
Dr Zakir
n he was also presented the prestigious
government of Malaysia's International
level too Mal Hijra award 2013 that is
hijri 1434 for significant service and
contribution to the development of Islam
worldwide after a span of about 11 and a
half years and it's a pleasure for me to
be back in kale in K by the king of
Malaysia
aonga Abdul halim Madam sha and he award
citation by the prime minister of
Malaysia datoseri Muhammad najib bin T
haaji Abdul razak on 5th November 2013
in quala Lampur Malaysia
Z night confir the Sha award for the
year 2013
[Music]